Professor Shelly Kagan:
We've been talking about the
question as to whether or not it
would be desirable to live
forever, whether immortality
would actually be a good thing,
as most of normally presume,
or whether in fact,
as Bernard Williams argues,
it would be undesirable.
The question we turned to was,
just let your imagination run
free.
Instead of asking what would it
be like to continue living a
longer kind of trajectory that
humans have in the real world
where you just get sicker and
more and more frail and
incapacitated,
ask yourself not whether
immortality of that sort
would be valuable,
but is it even so much as
possible to describe a
life that you would want to live
forever?
That's the question I left you
with last time.
I think I already tipped my
cards on this matter.
I'm inclined to agree with
Williams.
I think that no matter how we
try to fill in the blank,
it's a very long blank.
The crucial point here for us
is that immortality means not
just living a very long time or
even an extraordinarily long
time,
but literally living forever.
I think it's very difficult,
indeed I think it's impossible,
to think of anything you'd want
to do forever.
I have a friend who once
claimed to me that he wanted to
live forever so that he could
have Thai food every day for the
rest of,
well, the rest of eternity.
I like Thai food just fine,
but the prospect of having Thai
food day after day after day
after day for thousands,
millions, billions,
trillions of years no longer
seems an attractive proposal.
It seems like it becomes some
kind of a nightmare.
And the same way that I
indicated previously that
although I like chocolate--I
love chocolate--the
prospect of having to eat more
and more and more and more and
more chocolate,
eventually the idea becomes a
sickening one.
Think of any activity.
Some of you may enjoy doing
crossword puzzles,
and perhaps doing crossword
puzzles a couple hours a day is
enjoyable.
But imagine doing crossword
puzzles every day for 10 years,
1,000 years,
a million years,
a billion years,
a trillion years.
Eventually, presumably,
so it seems to me,
you'd end up saying,
"I'm really tired of crossword
puzzles."
Sure, there'd be some new
particular puzzle you hadn't
seen before, but you'd sort of
step up a level and say,
"Although I haven't seen this
particular one before,
I've seen crossword puzzles
before.
There's really nothing new
under the sun here.
The fact that I haven't seen
this particular combination of
words isn't enough to make it
interesting."
Well, crossword puzzles aren't
a very deep subject,
and we might wonder whether or
not we would do better if we
were engaged in something more
mentally challenging than that.
This may indicate something
unusual about me,
but I rather like math.
And the prospect of having a
lot of time to pursue math
problems of a richer and deeper
sort seems fairly attractive.
Yet even there,
when I imagine an eternity of
thinking about math--or for that
matter,
an eternity of thinking about
philosophy, which I obviously
like even more than math--the
prospect seems an unattractive
one.
I can't think of any activity
I'd want to do forever.
Now, of course,
that's a bit of a cheat because
the claim isn't to spend
eternity doing math problems and
nothing but math problems.
Right now, with our 50,80,
100 years, we don't fill our
day doing only one kind of
activity.
We fill our day with a mixture
of activities.
But it doesn't really help
having Thai food for dinner and
Chinese for lunch.
Or perhaps Chinese on Monday,
Wednesdays, and Fridays and
Thai on Saturdays and Sundays
and spending two hours in the
afternoon doing math and three
hours in the morning doing
philosophy.
That sounds like a pretty
pleasant life.
But again, if you think of the
possibility of doing that for
all eternity and never
getting away from it,
never being free from it,
the positive dream of
immortality, I think,
becomes a nightmare.
Well again, maybe I'm not just
being creative enough in my
imagination.
Different former colleague of
mine once talked about the
prospect of having a kind of
heavenly vision of the divine.
Maybe that would be desirable
forever.
And she described it as,
think of what it's like to have
a really great conversation with
a friend that you wish would
never end,
except God's this infinitely
rich friend and so the
conversation ends up seeming
desirable forever.
Well again, I can say the
words, but when I try to imagine
that possibility and take it
seriously,
at least speaking personally,
it doesn't--it doesn't hold up.
No friend that I've ever talked
with is one that I actually
would want to spend
eternity talking to.
And it's of course possible to
say, well, just imagine a friend
that you would want to talk
through all eternity to.
But the whole point is,
I can't imagine what that would
be like.
When I do my best to imagine
some kind of existence that
would be desirable or attractive
forever, it just doesn't work.
It becomes a nightmare.
Well again, maybe what we need
to do is not so much just
imagine the same cycling going
through week after week after
week, but whole careers.
Maybe you could spend 50 or 100
years pursuing philosophy as
your career.
And then 50 or 100 years
pursuing math as your career.
And 50 or 100 years traveling
around the world.
And 50 or 100 years being an
artist and working on your water
colors, or whatever it is.
Well, that certainly seems like
we could probably get more time
out of that.
But again, the crucial point to
remember is that forever is
literally forever.
There's no life that I'm
able to imagine for myself
that's one that I would want to
take on forever.
Well, you might say surely
there could be creatures that
would want to live
forever, that would enjoy an
eternal existence.
And I think that's probably
right.
So scientists have learned how
to do the following.
There are certain--you can take
a rat and put an electrode in
his brain.
If you put the electrode in
just the right place,
then when the electrode gets
turned on,
it stimulates the pleasure
center in the rat's brain and it
gets a little burst of pleasure,
a pretty intense burst of
pleasure.
And in fact,
you can take the wire,
the electrode,
and hook it up to a lever and
teach the rat how to push the
lever and give itself a little
burst of pleasure.
Now, what happens to rats when
you do this?
Well, maybe unsurprisingly,
what they do is,
they keep pressing the lever.
Indeed, they press the lever
and they'll stop eating,
they're no longer interested in
sex.
They basically just give
themselves this little orgasmic
burst of pleasure--well,
until they die.
Now well, of course,
it's too bad the rat dies,
but if we imagine the rat not
being mortal--perhaps you've got
it on IV so it's getting its
nutrients that way--then perhaps
it's easy to imagine the rat
simply pressing the lever
forever,
getting this intense burst of
pleasure and being content to do
that for all eternity.
So if it's so easy to imagine
that for the rat,
why not for us?
Why not just put our own
orgasmitron hat on with a
little--not rat lever,
but now human lever--with the
electrodes stimulating our own
brains so that we get this
intense burst of pleasure?
And just imagine this intense
burst of pleasure going on
forever.
What could be more desirable
than that?
Except, when I think about
that, and I invite you to think
about that, I don't actually
find that an especially
attractive prospect.
Mind you, it's not that I think
we couldn't be stimulated to get
pleasure forever.
It's that there's something
that distinguishes humans from
rats.
When I--No doubt I would enjoy
it.
And no doubt you would enjoy it
for a very long time.
But I imagine that after a
period, there'd be this--Well,
humans have this ability to
look down on their experiences,
or step back from their
experiences, and assess them.
Even now, as I'm sitting here
lecturing to you,
part of me, because of this
very question that I'm raising,
is thinking about how's the
lecture going,
and am I going to get through
what I need to get through,
and so forth and so on.
We can reflect on our first
order or base level experiences.
Now, imagine then that you're
in the pleasure-making machine.
After a while,
part of you is going to start
asking, "Huh,
say, it feels the same as it
was yesterday,
and the day before that and the
day before that.
I imagine this is how it's
going to feel tomorrow,
and the day after that and the
day after that."
And eventually this question
would start, "Is this really all
there is to life,
just simple pleasure like
this?"
The thing about being human is,
unlike the rat,
you're not just going to stay
caught up in the moment.
You're going to take this
meta-level or higher level
standpoint, look down at the
pleasure and wonder,
"Is this all that there is to
life?"
And I think eventually that
question would gnaw at you and
sour and override the pleasure.
Eventually, you'd become
horrified that you were,
in effect, stuck in this
rat-like existence.
Of course, the human part of
you is able to say there's
more to you than this
rat-like existence.
But precisely,
the human part of you is going
to rebel at the unending parade
of simple rat-like pleasures.
So, I don't think an eternity
like that would be such a good
thing.
Maybe it would be for a rat,
but not for a human.
Of course, we could perhaps
deal with that problem by making
us more rat-like in terms of our
thinking processes.
Perhaps the right kind of
lobotomy would do the trick.
I don't actually know exactly
what it would take,
but you just cut off and snip
the relevant nerve endings so
that we're no longer able to
engage in that higher order
thinking.
No longer able to raise the
question, "Is this all there
is?"
No longer able to step back
from the first order pleasure.
No doubt, you can turn us into
creatures like rats in that way.
And then, I presume,
we would continue to enjoy it
forever.
But the question isn't really,
is there something you could do
to a human being so that he'd be
happy, or at least enjoying
himself, forever?
It's rather,
do you, sitting here now,
thinking about that kind of
life, do you want that for
yourself?
Do you want to be lobotomized
where that's the only way,
at least that we've got so far,
to imagine a life that you
would enjoy forever.
Sure.
Screw me up enough and maybe
I'd enjoy being alive forever.
But that doesn't mean that I
now want that for myself.
That doesn't seem to me to be
some gift you've given me.
That seems to me to be some
horrible penalty you've imposed
on me, that you've reduced me
from being a human being,
able to engage in the full
range of reflection,
and simply turned me into
something like a rat.
So again, when the question is
posed, "Is there a kind of life
that I or you would want to live
forever?"
the question I'm asking is a
question to you,
here, now.
Is there a kind of life that
you would want to live
forever?
Not that, if we altered you,
that that product would want to
have forever.
I can't see how to do it.
Well look, there's one other
possibility.
Instead of imagining
lobotomizing us,
turning us into rats,
suppose we just say,
look, the problem is really
this.
The problem,
of course, is boredom.
The problem is tedium.
The problem is that you get
tired of doing math after a
while, 100 years,
1,000 years,
a million years,
whatever it is.
You say, "Yeah,
here's a math problem I haven't
solved before,
but so what?
I've just done so much math,
it holds no appeal to me
before."
Or, you cycle through all the
great art museums in the world
and you say, "Yeah,
I've seen these Picassos.
I've seen these Rembrandts
before.
I've gotten what there is to
get out of them.
Isn't there anything new?"
And the problem is no, no.
We've--even if there's
literally new things,
they're not the new kinds of
things that can still engage us
afresh.
Well, what's the solution to
that?
The solution to that might be a
kind of amnesia,
a kind of progressive lack of
memory.
So here I am,
100 years, 1,000 years,
around 500,000 years,
whatever it may be.
You're getting pretty bored
with life.
But if we now introduce some
progressive memory,
so--a progressive memory
loss--so that I know longer
remember what I did 100,000
years earlier.
And by the time I'm a million,
I no longer remember what I was
doing when I was a lad of
500,000.
And by the time I'm a million
and a half, I no longer remember
what was happening in oh,
back, back.
I know I was alive, perhaps.
Or maybe I don't even remember
that I was alive.
I sort of remember the last
10-20,000 years and that's it.
And while we're at it,
why don't we have overhauling
of your interests and desires,
your tastes?
So your tastes in music evolve
over thousands of years.
And your tastes in art or
literature.
Or, you like math now but then
you lose your taste in math,
and you become the kind of
person perhaps who's interested
in Chinese poetry,
whatever it is.
Wouldn't that do it?
If we had this sort of
progressive all-radical
alteration, not just minimal
alteration,
but radical alterations of my
memory, my beliefs,
my desires, my tastes.
Couldn't that be a kind of
existence that would be forever
enjoyable and yet it wouldn't be
a rat-like existence?
I'd be engaged in studying
Chinese poetry.
I'd be engaged in doing math.
I'd be engaged in studying
astronomy, what have you.
That's far better than the
rat's existence.
And yet, at no point do I
become bored,
because, roughly,
I'm so different from period to
period to period.
Well, I think actually,
you probably could tell a story
where that was true,
especially if we throw in
enough doses of memory loss.
But this case should remind you
of something,
because this case is one that
we've actually discussed before
under the label of "Methuselah."
Methuselah, remember,
when we talked about personal
identity, we imagined
somebody--much shorter-lived at
that time.
I think it was several hundred
years, a hundred years old,
200 years old,
300 years old,
600,700, 800,900 years old.
By the time Methuselah was 900
years old, he no longer
remembered anything about his
childhood.
What I found when I thought
about the Methuselah case was,
even though it was me at age
800,
the same person as the one
who's standing here in front of
you now, it didn't really
matter.
I said, "So what?"
When I thought about what I
wanted in survival,
it wasn't enough that there be
somebody in the distant future
that be me.
That wasn't good enough.
It had to be somebody with a
similar enough
personality.
You tell me,
"Oh there's going to be
somebody alive.
It'll be you,
but it'll be completely unlike
you.
Different tastes,
no memories of having taught
philosophy and so forth."
I say, that's all rather
interesting from a metaphysical
point of view,
but speaking personally,
I don't really care.
It's of no interest to me to
survive, and merely saying the
mantra, "Oh, but it's me"
doesn't make it more desirable
to me.
What I want isn't merely for
somebody to be me.
I want them to be sufficiently
like me.
And the problem with the
Methuselah case was,
go far enough out,
it's no longer sufficiently
like me.
So I don't really care that
there'll be somebody out there
who's still me,
if they're so unlike me now.
But that's, after all,
what we've just described,
in imagining the cycling with
the memory loss.
Yeah, there'll be somebody
around 100,000 years from now,
500,000 years from now,
and maybe they'll be me.
I don't care.
It doesn't give me what I
want when I want to
survive.
So perhaps we should put the
point in the form of a dilemma.
Could immortality be something
worth having forever?
Well, on the one hand,
if we make it be me and
similar to me,
boredom's going to set in.
The only way to avoid that is
to lobotomize me,
and that's not desirable.
If we make--If we solve the
problem of boredom setting in
with progressive memory loss and
radical personality changes,
maybe boredom won't set in,
but it's not anything that I
especially want for myself.
It just doesn't matter to me
that it's me,
anymore than it would matter to
me if they just tell me,
"Oh, there'll be somebody else
around there who will like
Chinese poetry."
So, is there a way of living
forever that's attractive to me?
I can't think of what it would
look like.
So, I agree with Bernard
Williams when he says
immortality wouldn't be
desirable.
It would actually be a
nightmare, something you would
long to free yourself from.
Now, having said that,
of course, that doesn't in any
way mean that it's a good thing
that we die when we do at 50 or
80 or 100.
From the fact that after
100,000 years or a million years
or whatever it is,
eventually life would grow
tiresome, that hardly shows that
life has grown tiresome after 50
years or 80 years or 100.
I don't believe
we'll--I'll--come close to
scratching the surface of what I
would enjoy doing,
by the time I've died.
And I imagine the same thing is
true for you.
So perhaps the best form of
life would be not immortality;
I think that would be not
particularly desirable.
And not what we've got now,
where you live after a mere
drop of 50 or 80 or 100 years.
But rather, the best thing I
suppose would be to be able to
live as long as you wanted.
This is the sort of thing that
Julian Barnes basically imagines
in the chapter "The Dream" that
I had you take a look at.
Barnes envisions heaven as a
situation which you can stick
around doing what you want to do
for as long as you want to do
it.
But Barnes says,
eventually you'll have enough.
And once you've had enough,
you can put an end to it.
Still--the fact that we can put
an end to it,
that's the point we've already
been flagging,
that immortality would not be
so good.
But the new thought here is
what would be good would be
being able to live until you
were satisfied,
until you'd gotten what goods
there were to get out of life.
What all this suggests,
then, and this is a point that
I really made before,
is that the best understanding
of the deprivation account
doesn't say that what's bad is
the mere fact that we're going
to die.
If I'm right in thinking
immortality would be
undesirable, then the fact that
we're going to die is good,
because it guarantees that we
won't be immortal,
which would be a nightmare,
an unending nightmare.
Still, even though it's not a
bad thing that we will die,
it could still be a bad thing
that we die when we do.
It could still be the case that
we die too soon.
According to the deprivaton
account, death is bad,
when it's bad,
because of the fact that it
deprives us of the good things
in life,
insofar as we would have
continued to get good things in
life.
But if life would no longer
have anything good to offer you,
if what you then would have had
would have been something
negative instead of something
positive,
then at that point,
dying wouldn't actually be a
bad thing.
It would be a good thing.
Death is bad insofar as it
deprives you of a chunk of life
that would have been good.
Insofar as it deprives you of a
future that would have been bad,
then death's not actually bad,
it's actually good.
Now, in stating this view this
way, I'm obviously presupposing
that we can make these kinds of,
at least, overall judgments in
terms of the quality of your
life, how well off you are.
Is life giving you good things,
or is life giving you bad
things?
Is it worth continuing to live,
or is it not worth continuing
to live?
So, I want to turn to that
topic and spend oh,
probably the better part of a
lecture or so.
The rest of today and some of
next time talking about the
question of, well,
what is it for a life to
go well?
How do we assess what makes a
life--a good life versus a bad
life?
And I don't mean morally good
life.
I mean, good for the
person whose life it is.
A life that you think,
"I'm benefiting from having
this life."
What are the ingredients or
constituents or elements of a
good life versus a bad life?
And of course,
since it's not just black and
white, good life or bad life,
but various shades of gray,
better lives and worse lives,
what's the yardstick by virtue
of which we measure better and
worse lives?
What goes into a good life?
Now, in thinking about this
question, this is--you might
think of the topic as the nature
of wellbeing.
And like all the other topics
we've talked about in this
class, it's a complicated
subject, about which one could
spend a great deal of time.
All we're going to do here is
really just, once again,
scratch the surface.
But the very first point that
needs to be made,
I think, is this.
If you start listing all the
things worth having in life,
it might seem as though you
couldn't possibly come to any
general organizing principles.
Think about it.
What's worth having?
Well yeah, jobs are worth
having.
Money's worth having.
Sex is worth having.
Chocolate's worth having.
Ice cream's worth having.
Air conditioners are worth
having.
What are some of the things
worth avoiding?
Well, being blind is worth
avoiding.
Being mugged is worth avoiding.
Diarrhea is worth avoiding.
Pain's worth avoiding.
Getting unemployed is worth
avoiding.
War is worth avoiding.
What kind of systematicity
could we possibly bring to all
of this?
Well, the crucial,
I think, first distinction is
this.
We need to separate between
those things that are good
because of what they lead to.
That is, more strictly,
only because of what
they lead to.
And those things that are
valuable for their own sake or
in their own right.
Take something like a job.
A job's worth having.
Why is a job worth having?
Well, a job's worth having
because, well,
among other things,
it gives you money.
All right.
Money's worth having.
Why is money worth having?
Well, money's worth having
because, among other things,
you can buy ice cream with it.
All right.
Why is ice cream worth having?
Well, ice cream's worth having
because when I eat ice cream it
gives me this pleasurable
sensation.
All right.
Why is the pleasurable
sensation worth having?
At this point,
we get a different kind of
answer.
At this point,
we say something like,
pleasure is worth having for
its own sake.
The other things were valuable
as a means, ultimately to
pleasure.
But pleasure is worth having
for its own sake.
The things that are valuable as
a means we can say are
instrumentally valuable.
The things that are worth
having for their own sake,
philosophers call intrinsically
valuable.
If we look back at that long,
open-ended list of things that
were good or bad,
we'll find that most of the
things on that list are
instrumentally good.
They're good because of what
they lead to.
Or, for that matter,
instrumentally bad.
Why is disease bad?
Well, among other things,
it means perhaps that you can't
enjoy yourself.
So it deprives you of pleasure.
Or perhaps it means because
you're sick, you can't hold your
job down.
If you can't hold your job
down, you can't get the money
and so forth and so on.
Ultimately, most of the
negative things on that list
were instrumentally bad.
Most of the good things on that
list were instrumentally good.
If we want to get anyplace on
the question about the nature of
the good life,
what we need to focus on is not
the instrumental goods and bads,
but rather the intrinsic goods
and bads.
You've got to ask yourself,
"What's worth having for its
own sake?
What's worth having in and of
itself?"
Well, one natural suggestion is
that pleasure is worth having
for its own sake and pain is
probably worth avoiding for its
own sake.
So pain's probably
intrinsically bad;
pleasure is intrinsically good.
Notice by the by that logically
speaking, there is nothing that
stops the very same thing from
being both.
And actually you can get other
weird combinations.
You go to the dentist and he
pokes you.
He says, "Does this hurt?
Does that hurt?"
in order to try to figure out
where there's gum disease.
And the pain that he causes is
intrinsically bad.
In and of itself it's bad.
Yet, for all that,
it's being useful there.
It's providing a means of
deciding where the gum has
decayed.
And that allows the dentist to
improve your gums,
which avoids more pain down the
road.
So the pain you're suffering
now is actually
instrumentally valuable,
useful as a means,
even though it's
intrinsically bad.
Similarly, when I work,
I enjoy myself.
And so the pleasure I'm getting
then is intrinsically good.
But it's also instrumentally
good.
The fact that I'm enjoying
myself makes it easier for me to
work harder.
Perhaps I'm more productive,
I do better at my job.
So the pleasure is both
intrinsically valuable and
instrumentally valuable.
So there's no claiming that
things have to be one or the
other, but not both.
Still, in trying to get clear
about the nature of wellbeing,
the crucial thing to do is to
focus not on the question about
instrumental value,
but rather to focus on the
question of intrinsic value.
What things are worth having
for their own sake,
whether or not those things
also have instrumental value,
or what have you?
What things are worth having
for their own sake and what
things are worth avoiding for
their own sake?
Well, in giving these examples,
I've already indicated at least
two things that belong on the
list.
It seems pretty plausible to
think pleasure is intrinsically
good.
One thing, maybe not the only
thing, but at least one thing,
that goes into a life worth
having is enjoying it,
is pleasure.
And one thing that seems
intrinsically bad,
one thing that seems to reduce
the value of a life,
is pain.
Most of us agree then,
pleasure is intrinsically
valuable;
pain is intrinsically negative,
unvaluable, has anti-value.
Well, suppose we make for,
the moment, the bold
conjecture, the philosophical
claim,
that not only is pleasure and
the absence of pain,
not only is pleasure one
good thing and pain one
bad thing.
Suppose that's the entire list.
Suppose we conjecture that the
only thing intrinsically
valuable is pleasure and the
only thing intrinsically bad is
pain.
That view is called hedonism.
So hedonism is a view that many
people are attracted to,
perhaps some of you believe.
It's got a very simple theory
of the nature of wellbeing.
Being well off is a matter of
experiencing pleasure and
avoiding or minimizing the
experience of pain.
That's hedonism.
A little later we'll turn to
the question of,
well, if hedonism is not the
right story, what else belongs
on the list, or is it the right
story?
We'll turn to that question a
little bit later.
But notice that if we've got
hedonism or, for that matter as
we'll see, some other theories
of wellbeing,
if we've got hedonism,
we're able to make the kinds of
evaluations that I was helping
myself to when I started talking
a few minutes ago about well,
you know, if what life would
hold for you is bad overall,
then you're better off dying
and so forth.
What's going on when we make
those judgments?
Well, the hedonist offers us a
very simple straightforward
answer.
In deciding whether what life
holds for you is worth having,
better than nothing,
you, roughly speaking,
add up all the good times and
subtract all the bad times and
see whether the net balance is
positive or negative.
Add up all the pleasures,
subtract all the pains.
If the balance is positive,
your life is worth living.
And the more positive the
balance, the bigger the number,
the more your life is worth
living.
If the balance is negative
though, think about what that
would mean.
If the balance was negative,
you're saying your future holds
more pain overall than pleasure.
And that's a negative.
You'd be better off,
well, you'd be better off dead,
right?
Because if you were dead,
you'd have neither pleasure nor
pain.
That's going to presumably be
given--mathematically if we gave
it a number, we'd slap a zero on
that.
No positive number,
no negative number.
That's a zero.
Obviously, if the balance of
pleasure over pain is positive,
that's better than zero.
But if the balance of pain over
pleasure--If there's more pain
than pleasure so that the
balance is negative,
that's worse than zero.
That's a life not worth having.
That's what the hedonist says.
Now, there's different ways of
working out the details of the
hedonist view.
It's not, after all,
as though all pleasures count
equally or all pains count
equally.
The pain of stubbing your toe
obviously doesn't count for
nearly as much as the pain of a
migraine,
which doesn't count nearly as
the pain of being tortured.
And so we might need to work
out various, more complicated,
formulas here,
where we multiply the pain
times its duration and take into
account its intensity,
get the sheer quantity
of pain that way.
And similarly,
pleasures can be longer
lasting, or more intense.
You can imagine how some of
those details might go,
and then some of the questions
get rather tricky.
But for our purposes,
we don't really need to worry
about the details.
The thought is,
roughly, weigh up the pleasures
and pains in some appropriate
way.
Add up the pleasures.
Add up the pains.
See whether the grand total of
pleasures is greater than the
grand totals of pain.
The more positive the number,
the better your life.
Now, armed with an approach
like this, we can do more than
just evaluate entire lives.
Well, one thing we can do is
just that.
We can evaluate entire lives.
There you are at the pearly
gates and you look back on your
life and you could,
in principle,
add up all the pleasures,
add up all the pains,
subtract the pains from the
pleasures and ask yourself,
"How good a life did I have?
How well off was I,
having lived that life?"
And perhaps then you could
imagine alternative lives.
If only I had chosen to become
a doctor, instead of having
chosen to become a lawyer.
How much better off or worse
off would I have been?
Or if I decided to become an
artist or a scholar or a beach
bum or a farmer,
how much better off or worse
off would I have been?
How much greater or smaller
would the number go?
Despite my talking about
numbers, of course,
there's no particular
assumption that we can really
give precise numbers to this.
And we certainly don't think
that in fact most of us are in
the position to actually crank
out any kind of accurate number.
Most of us don't know enough to
know with a high degree of
accuracy how things would have
gone had I decided to become a
farmer instead of a philosopher.
Still, the hedonist isn't
saying from a practical point of
view we can necessarily do this.
But in theory,
in principle,
this is what we're wondering
about when we face choices.
We can ask ourselves,
"What would our life look like?
Would it be better or worse?"
And the yardstick that we're at
least doing our best to apply is
one of measuring up the pleasure
and subtracting the pain.
And of course,
the hedonist will also hasten
to point out that just because
we can't do this perfectly or
infallibly,
that doesn't mean we can't make
educated guesses,
right?
You're trying to decide should
you go to Yale for college or
should you go to Ohio State or
Harvard or wherever else you got
into,
and you ask yourself,
well, you try to project your
future and you ask,
"Where do I think I'd be better
off?
Which of these branches that
are available to me,
the branches of my life story,
which is the one in which the
future from here on out holds
more pleasure and holds less
pain?"
That's how the hedonist says we
should think about it.
And notice by the by,
that when we make choices about
our future, from the hedonist
point of view,
at least, there's no particular
need to dwell a whole lot on the
past, because what's done is
done.
You're not going to alter how
much pleasur you enjoyed
previously, how much suffering
you've undergone previously.
What's open is the future.
And so we're able to evaluate
not just lives as a whole,
looking back at the pearly
gate.
We're able to evaluate lives
from here on out.
Which of the various futures
that are open to me are likely
to give me the better life,
leave me better off,
measured in terms of pleasure
or pain?
And we do our best,
however good or bad that may
be.
We do our best to make such
comparative evaluations.
And of course,
we can do more than just
evaluate the entire rest of my
life.
We can evaluate the next year
or the next six months or,
for that matter,
just this evening.
I can talk about,
well, what should I do tonight?
Should I stay home and work on
my paper?
Should I go to the party?
Where will I be better off
tonight?
Well, I'll probably enjoy
myself more at the party than I
will working on the paper.
And the paper's not due for a
while and so forth.
We make evaluations not just of
entire lives,
but of chunks of lives.
All right.
That's what we can do if we
accept hedonism.
But haven't yet asked,
should we accept
hedonism?
Now, it will not come as news
to me if I were to learn that
several of you,
maybe even many of you,
in this class accept hedonism.
It's a very popular view.
Not just among philosophers
where it's a view that's been
around as long as there's been
philosophy, but among people in
the street.
It's a very tempting view to
think, what makes life worth
having and the only thing worth
having for its own sake,
is having pleasure and avoiding
pain.
But for all that,
despite the popularity of that
view, I'm inclined to think it
must be wrong.
It's not that I think pleasure
isn't good and pain isn't bad.
Where hedonism goes wrong is
when they say it's the
only thing that matters.
I'm inclined to think there's
more to the best kind of life
than just having pleasure and
avoiding pain.
Now, I already revealed that,
when I was talking about the
rat lever machine.
I said, hook me up to that
machine and I'll enjoy myself.
But I don't want that for
myself.
Why?
Because there's more to
life than just pleasure and the
absence of pain,
or so it seems to me.
Still, we might say,
but the rat lever is not the
only kind of pleasures there
are.
There's all these pleasures of
experiencing art and seeing a
beautiful sunset.
And I don't know about you,
but at least when I imagine the
rat lever thing,
it's a sort of simple,
undifferentiated pleasure.
So, that really won't do the
trick in giving us the best
quality pleasures of the kinds
that humans most crave--the
pleasures of friendship and
discussion and sexual intimacy.
These pleasures the rat lever
machine wasn't giving us.
So couldn't hedonism still be
true?
Couldn't it still be the case
that as long as we take into
account the importance of
getting the right kinds
of pleasures,
then really pleasure is what
it's all about and all that it's
about?
No, I think that's still not
right.
But indeed, we'll need to move
to something fancier than the
rat lever machine.
Here, the relevant thought
experiment was suggested by
Robert Nozick,
a philosopher who died a few
years ago, taught for many years
at Harvard.
Nozick invited us to imagine an
experience machine.
So, suppose that the scientists
have discovered a way not just
to stimulate the particular
little pleasure center of the
brain,
but basically to--give you
basically, completely realistic
virtual reality.
So that when you are hooked up
to the machine,
it seems to you exactly the
same on the inside as it would
seem to you if you really
were--and now fill in the blank.
You could have the identical
experience of climbing Mount
Everest, let's say,
so that you'll feel the wind
bracing you.
Of course, you won't really
feel any wind.
Strictly speaking,
that's not true,
because you're not up on Mount
Everest.
There is no wind.
What's really going on is
you're floating in the
psychologist's tank in their lab
with the electrodes hooked up
your brain.
But you don't know that you are
floating in the tank.
Hooked up to the machine,
you believe you are climbing
Mount Everest.
You feel the thrill of having
made it to the top and the wind
bracingly striking your chin and
you feel the satisfaction and
you've got the memories of
having almost died when the rope
broke before.
It's not like being at the IMAX.
The crucial point,
when you're at the IMAX is,
although it's very realistic,
part of you is aware that
you're just in the theatre.
But on the experience machine,
you don't know you're just in
the lab.
When you're on the experience
machine, you've got--your brain
is being stimulated in such a
way that you've got the
identical experience on the
inside to what it would feel
like if you really were
doing these things.
So, imagine a life on the
experience machine.
Imagine plugging in the tape.
Says something about how old
this example is that we talk
about plugging in the tapes.
Imagine plugging in the DVD,
or whatever it is,
with all of the best possible
experiences.
Whatever you think those are.
Here, you might imagine
different people disagreeing
about--oh, but throw in
something--but if what you want
to do is write the great
American novel,
then you've got the experience
of staying up late at night not
knowing how to make the plot
work out,
crushing pieces of paper and
throwing them away.
Crushing your computer,
or whatever it is that you do
as you write the great American
novel.
Or you want to be finding the
cure for cancer.
So you've got exactly the
experience you would have if you
were working in your lab having
the brilliant breakthrough when
you finally realize what the
combination is that would make
the right antibody,
whatever it is.
Or if you want to be observing
all the most beautiful sunsets
and the most exotic locales,
you've got exactly the
experience you would have if you
were doing all these things.
That's life on the experience
machine.
You're not doing any of
it.
You're floating in the lab.
But the experiences are
identical.
Now, ask yourself then,
would you want to spend your
life hooked up to the experience
machine?
Ask yourself,
how would you feel if you
discovered now that you
have been living your
life hooked up to an experience
machine?
Now, I've got to make a
footnote here.
This perfectly glorious
philosophical example has been
ruined in recent years by the
movie The Matrix.
Because whenever I tell this
story now, people start saying,
"Oh, well the evil machines are
busy using your body as a
battery" or whatever it was in
the movie,
right?
And "What if people are
nefariously feasting on my liver
while I'm having these little
experiences?"
Don't imagine any of that.
It's not that the evil
scientist is just deliberately
deceiving you so as to conduct
his nefarious experiments.
Nothing like that.
And similarly,
while we're at it--this is not
a Matrix-like worry--if
you're worried about,
yeah, but what's happening to
world poverty while I'm doing
all of this?
Just imagine that everybody's
hooked up to experience
machines, but everybody's got
the best possible tapes.
Now you ask yourself,
what I'm asking you to ask
yourself, is would you want to
spend your life hooked up to the
experience machine?
I'm not talking about,
wouldn't it be interesting to
try it out for a week or a month
or even a year?
And indeed, the question,
strictly speaking,
isn't even would life on the
experience machine be better
than it is now?
Although it would make me very,
very sad to discover this,
I suppose it's possible some of
you have such bad lives that
moving on to the experience
machine would be a step up.
That's not the question.
The question is,
does life on the experience
machine give you
everything worth having
in life?
Everything worth having
in life.
Is it the best possible form of
human existence?
According to the hedonists,
the answer's got to be,
it has to be "yes."
Life on the experience machine
is perfect, as long as you've
got the right tape plugged in.
So, you've got the best
possible balance of wonderful
pleasures and wonderful,
fantastic experiences,
since that's all there is to
human wellbeing.
By hypothesis,
the machine is giving us that.
There couldn't possibly be
anything more.
anything missing.
But when I think about the
question, would I want to spend
my life hooked up to an
experience machine?
the answer is "no."
And I imagine that for most of
you, when you ask yourself,
would you want your entire life
to be spent hooked up to the
experience machine?
your answer is "no."
But if the answer is "no," then
that means hedonism's got to be
wrong.
If life on the experience
machine is not everything,
then there's more to the best
possible life than getting the
insides right.
The experience machine gets the
pleasures right,
gets the experiences right,
gets the mental states right,
it gets the insides right,
but if life on the experience
machine isn't all that's worth
wanting out of life,
then there's more to the best
possible life than getting the
insides right.
What we've got to turn to next
time, then, is the question,
what else might it be?
Okay.